what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champions
people say all i do is score penalties
but i also
dive to win those penalties oh yeah
first american to wear the bars in
jersey america
do you think it's so easy for bayern to
win the league it takes a lot of careful
planning to buy all the best players
from all the other teams
when the weather gets colder it's a good
time to reconsider florida we've got
loads of hot spots
hurry up mate the ladies will be here
any minute alas we brought you some
lunch huh
what you doing relax bro we're digging a
contraband tunnel
jaden if you want to play for manchester
united one day
you can't be breaking the rules all
willy-nilly that's how you end up
slipping
slip on this who doesn't think
that's it you need to learn some respect
right now you have it pretty good at the
mansion but you never know
what next season brings time you see how
the other half lives
on a tour of europa house no
i can't go back you can't make me
[Music]
have a good evening
hello anyone in
his body i do not sneak up on people
like that
welcome to europa house sorry about the
exploding light bulbs
they're incandescent
as a former juvenile delinquent i've
developed a process for getting through
to young players and setting them
straight
i'll just scare the [ __ ] out of them
right this way
up-and-coming talents let me be your
ghoulish guide through this
house of mayor we start every day here
with a free breakfast buffet
oh that's not so bad but it's also not
so good because there's no eggs
here we have our all-inclusive community
fitness center
oh nice but it's just one elliptical
that's not how you're supposed to use
that
want to take a dip on our stadio
olimpico size swimming pool
we're too bad because there's no towels
oh no they're cold
check this out
[Music]
what happened to those guys oh nothing
that's just their awakens
i was trying to show you how small the
rooms is
i don't like it here it's scary what's
scary
this guy scariest thing about him is his
cat being
i'm sorry you think i'm funny i'm funny
how
i mean funny like a clown i'm not a
clown
this guy's a clown i do birthday parties
bar and bad mitzvahs
quinceaneras and i've even done some
football games
look mate you can't scare me so stop
trying it's just embarrassing
oh you don't think i'm scary all right
then
i'll show you something scary
[Music]
what is this place it's a sauna
but it never gets hot go ahead take a
look-see
what was that anyone fancy alone
shall reveal your fate
ah phil food and hope of angling like
so many talents before you till a little
injury will become a persistent one and
before you know it your contract is up
for renegotiation and you find yourself
smiling through the pain as you hold up
oh west ham
shut no i don't like people blowing
bubbles at me
anzu fatty they call you the next messy
boss
like beaujon befaria it all goes wrong
you ask for more play in time but
instead you're sold to a portuguese club
with a buyback clause i got never
brought back
okay brendan i think that's enough
they're just young lads and you
jaden sanjor
your fortune is just tree letters
long em
[Music]
phew thanks mate you really showed me i
need to shape up
so i don't end up like you ah another
successful role modeling by
jamie vardy bon voyage lads
don't forget to write to your new mentor
jamie vardy
i come closer if it weren't for me ankle
[Music]
bracelet
[Music]
is
[Music]
here use this to like and subscribe to
br football
hong kong